the fbi made fundamental errors in its
sexual abuse investigation of former usa
gymnastics doctor
larry nassar now that's according to a
government watchdog report
the justice department's inspector
general accuses the fbi of failing to
respond to nassar's allegations
with the utmost urgency that they
deserved
the report also says about 70 or more
young athletes were allegedly
sexually abused by nassar after the
bureau first learned about the
accusations but before his arrest more
than a year
later nasser is serving what amounts to
a life sentence after pleading guilty to
multiple charges
hundreds of girls and young women say he
sexually abused them
under the premise of medical treatments
one of his accusers former team usa
gymnastics jessica howard
described her ordeal to dr john lepuc in
a 60 minutes report back in 2017.
i remember thinking something was
off but i didn't feel like i was able to
say anything
because he was you know this very high
profile doctor and i was very lucky
to be at the ranch working with him did
any of the other girls in your cabin
talk to you about dr nasser yes
the girls would say yeah he touches you
funny
howard also testified to congress about
the abuse and was one of
more than 200 women who gave impact
statements at nassar's trial
jessica howard is with us now only on
cbs this morning good morning to you
jessica it's good to see you again
to say i walked right past you because i
i remember you as a brunette but we're
really glad that you're here
i can only imagine what this fbi report
has done
to you or how it's made you feel has it
been triggering
in any way for you it has but in a
slightly different way than
the triggers began at the beginning of
this process
it used to be fiery and outraged like
how can this happen
and now i don't know i i guess i've come
to expect that nothing will be done
but again you're talking about the fbi
yeah
the fbi is one of the most trusted
institutions in our country so reading
this
list of horrible criminal activity
that actually has a human cost and
resulted in the sexual abuse
of more than 70 we think closer to 120
new victims who
were as young as eight so it's not that
they just messed up
it's not that they just didn't they
fumbled around and messed up
they actually have affected the lives of
at least 70 to 120
young girls do you think all along the
way so many people messed up in this
case
we're going to focus on the fbi today
because of the report
but when you look back at the big
picture do you see that it's much bigger
than what it appears to be
it's it's astounding how massive it is
and again unfortunately maybe i'm
cynical maybe i've just been through too
much at this point
to to make excuses for anyone
but it is not people messing up it's
people turning
away it's people not paying attention
it's people
deciding not to act and
that to me is is the most heinous
heinous way you can treat a child
yeah so when you when you read you read
the entire report
yes i skimmed some parts but yes yeah i
can't imagine what that was like for you
the recommendations out of this are new
policies and training for the fbi
what do you make of that again
throughout this process there's been
revelations
um regularly um since 2017
that go back to 2015 you know um
and each and every single time
there is some some sort of
proof and facts that point out that
this has happened and this is the way it
happened and it was a failure
but at the very end like you get to page
104 of the report
and after reading all about all this
criminal activity
um they just say well we're going to try
to do better in the future
and that is not good enough anymore
jessica do you want criminal charges
brought against agents
absolutely i i i want congress
to get involved i want the doj to get
involved i want a special prosecutor
i want agents who were not maybe not
even mentioned in the report but you
cannot tell me
that between in usa gymnastics in the
u.s olympic committee and in the fbi
that it was only these one or two bad
bad players that's what they said about
larry
absolutely not true he's the only one in
prison yeah what are your thoughts about
larry i'm curious because when i learned
that he was married and had daughters
i was so surprised by that i don't know
why but i thought
he had little girls himself you know i'm
not sure of the details of what went
down
in larry's family um there there's been
talk but i don't pay attention to it and
i didn't know so you weren't aware that
he had a family
not at all he is now saying that he was
unfairly punished by the judge who
sentenced him
he's now seeking a new judge and
sentencing hearing what do you think
when you hear
he feels he's been unfairly punished
i mean
i've tried to see it from other points
of view i really have when other people
come up with these arguments and say
these things about how they've been
mistreated
but the actual truth is they have caused
so much damage and mistreated so many
people and are just
narcissistic um criminals maybe
psychopaths and they will never think
they were wrong
what are your thoughts about the
olympics next week and you know
many of these young women who are going
to be competing what are your thoughts
about them as we get ready to celebrate
you know i just hope that
in the middle of all the all the glory
and all the amazing accomplishments and
all of the amazing performances you're
going to see that these people have been
working towards
for for so many decades of their
existence
that that should be celebrated and they
should be uplifted
but we cannot forget
that to get to that point so many of
them especially in gymnastics
have suffered severe psychological
emotional
and sexual abuse at the hands of these
people
and um it wasn't stopped at one point it
was covered up
and lied about and to the fbi just as
hard to hear you
even say this today when you say that
they've been suffered from psychological
abuse
you have to and how are you getting
through jessica i was really worried
about you when you were
sitting back there well like i as i
mentioned
when this started coming out and before
the first time i got to visit you here
um
i wouldn't even let people my family
take pictures of me
i i was not well i was not well and this
began to grate
more and more and more on my on my
ability to
handle and deal in the ptsd was severe
and the side effects of ptsd and sexual
trauma
are real and it's taken me about four
years to to know within myself
that i'm going to be okay i can't
control
what congress is going to do or what the
president can do
or what any of these institutions can do
i don't trust them
and i don't believe in them but i do
believe that
i am doing what i can to help protect
future generations of athletes
and you are thank you so much jessica
for your courage for sharing your voice
people are watching and that can affect
the actions they take so thank you so
much for joining
us well we're gonna keep keep on keeping
on this is not over
thank you so much jessica howard